hello welcome to another one of my
doctor seven chalk and talk videos and
in this one i am actually addressing
a question which i decided instead of
actually being put to me i decided to
appropriate from one of my colleagues
the context is this we were having a
facebook discussion in which he was
talking about his medieval political
theory class
and
of course the bin laden
news that came up brought up the issue
of fundamentalism
and
he had said that his class actually
in some ways had to do with
fundamentalism and i said well
it doesn't make that much sense to say
that about about medievals
and here's the question that
oriented his class his medieval
political theory class
are fundamental is
medieval
or
anti-modern and i put the anti in
parentheses there because to be
anti-modern
in certain ways means actually being
preeminently modern as well
and part of the goal of his class was to
you know lead his
students through
some christian philosophers and some
muslim philosophers notably augustine
and aquinas
and to show them that
medieval philosophy and naval attitudes
towards religion and the
confluence of faith and reason
is something very different from
contemporary forms of what he was
calling fundamentalism and then i i you
know being the religious studies
scholarship of the task for using
fundamentalism in a very loose and what
i consider sloppy
and in some ways a responsible way and
he said yes the religious studies people
always get on me about this but i think
it has a certain utility and i do grant
that there is a certain utility in using
the term
i i don't think that these are actually
compatible
here's what i want to actually
talk about tonight then two different
topics
one what does it actually mean to be a
fundamentalist what does that mean in a
rigorous sense what does that mean in a
broader sense when does one legitimately
use a term and when does one
reinforce stereotypes
by using that term
and then i want to talk about the
issue of
time temporality
through history and how different ages
and different groups within those
different ages
understand
the flow of time the passage of time
and development
then i'm going to actually have a
suggestion
about
how best to understand
the notion of fundamentalism and some of
the other groups that we call
fundamentalist
in our time and we're using it in a very
uh non-rigorous loose sense
so
let's talk about fundamentalism to begin
with
now
this is something i would stress to my
students who religious studies classes
from the very beginning as soon as
somebody used that word outside what do
you mean by that word fundamentals
and as it usually turned out they didn't
actually mean unless they were a
fundamentalist themselves
what
the precise signification of the term is
instead what they meant was something
more like this very loose sense and yes
i i am in fact oversimplifying here this
is not a a false dilemma because i'm not
claiming that these are the only ways of
using the term but these are these are
two very prominent ways in which the
term gets used
usually they were using a very loose or
careless sense where they mean anybody
who
has you know fairly strongly held
traditional conservative
views on religious matters
and they're coming from a particular
faith tradition which usually they know
fairly well
they tend to be literalists about
whatever religious texts that they're
they're using
and they tend to be
fairly aggressive fairly
how to put it fairly in your face
fairly
confrontational
and condemnatory
does everyone who gets called the
fundamentalist meet this bill definitely
not and as a matter of fact it's used as
a slur this is part of why i'm against
using it in this sense
because unfortunately it gets used all
too carelessly
to
uh in a pejorative way to tar groups to
to dismiss opponents
instead of actually taking them
seriously and tackling them
intellectually by the way i am not a
fundamentalist i don't fit into the
fundamental spectrum whether you
want to talk in the straight sense or
even in many understandings of loose
sins but i think that you also shouldn't
call people fundamentalists when they're
not especially if your goal
is to dismiss them or to try to get
other people to not take them seriously
um
it's a convenient handle that gets used
but before we talk about that let's look
at the strict sense who were the actual
photographers
it's a 20th century movement within
protestant christianity within what we
could call
low church
protestant christianity
and it has to do
with with issues of
biblical criticism
and the inerrancy of the bible
and as a matter of fact there were these
books
while they were actually pamphlets
originally but you can get them in a
nice two volume version the fundamentals
this is the
stuff that made fundamentalists what
they are these are the actual
fundamentals why do they call them the
fundamentals well their view was
there were certain traditional bits of
christian doctrine that were absolutely
fundamental to the christian
message to the christian way of life to
salvation and if you compromised on
those you might be able to compromise on
some things but if you compromise on
those the whole thing is over it's no
longer christianity
so they are dealing with a particular
notion of the essence of christianity
they're also coming out of a late
protestant reformational type of thought
so you know a genuine fundamentalist
is you know would blanch at the notion
of one speaking of a catholic
fundamentalist or mormon fundamentalist
sects or islamic fundamentalists they
would say hey those aren't even
christians
hardcore fundamentalists don't consider
catholics to be christians
and they would say
you know
fundamentalist refers to those who
actually subscribe to the fundamentals
and go one step further this is how
fundamentalists are different from
evangelicals another
major group within the american
religious landscape and also within the
world
uh christian
religious landscape as well
how do they differ from evangelicals
well evangelicals think that if
you're dealing with people
who have a mistaken understanding of
things what are you supposed to do
you're supposed to event you're supposed
to preach the
gospel
you know that's the french
cognitive for it you're supposed to
evangelize
fundamentalists are basically
separatists
they say
look that doesn't work
you have to actually
separate yourself off from those people
who may claim to be believers but aren't
really believers
that's what's what you know that's one
of the big divides between actual
fundamentalists and evangelicals who get
called fundamentalists all the time
um and you know generally get called
fundamentalists by people who are either
ignorant of what the term really means
in the history of it and you know the
groups that it belongs to
or they're doing it deliberately to try
to discredit evangelicals by tying them
in with the
in some ways more radical and more
conservative fundamentalists
so yeah there's a loose or careless
sense of the term if we just look within
the christian spectrum you see that
there are quite a few people who
will call any conservative
christian of any group
a fundamentalist even when it doesn't
really make much sense you know to talk
of
catholic fundamentalists you're really
stretching the term and it's difficult
to figure out what exactly you mean it's
better to actually use some of the the
jargon that's out there like
you know the word traditional it's got
kind of hijacked or ultra montanus or
things like that to be you know specific
uh if you talk about
mormon fundamentalist sex out in the
desert that are still practicing
polygamy and occasionally getting gun
battles with each other um again you're
really stretching the term
same thing if you're applying it to
muslims i mean in one sense
any orthodox muslim is going to be a
fundamentalist because they believe that
the koran and the hadith are inspired
you know and that you you have to
any any real islamic life is going to
have to be oriented by them well that
makes almost everybody a fundamentalism
so that means that it's a sloppy use of
language that's not very very helpful if
we want to actually distinguish this
people speak of hindu fundamentalism as
well i think or jewish fundamentalism
and i think that this is not a very
helpful way of looking at things
where does that come from though
well
here's where i'm actually going to use
some chalk
let's think about the the old timeline
going from antiquity all the way through
modernity
we should probably put the
enlightenment
and the industrial revolution
and all those things in there as
well in the ancient world
did they have the conception as often
many people have had
of them that things are just completely
static or cyclical many people did did
all the ancients believe that
no as a matter of fact if you read
aristotle you will see aristotle
speaking about progress
talking about how things have changed
over time how perceptions how we now
understand
more
and projecting a little bit ahead as
well
very often the medievals are represented
as the ancients are represented as if
they have this static conception of the
universe or cyclical conception things
just you know keep on going the same way
if you're an attentive reader
of ancient philosophy you'll find out
that that's not always the case
and then there's this sort of notion
that well how did history get introduced
it got introduced through judaism and
christianity
that's a great oversimplification let's
say that that's actually actually true
though let's go with that
so christianity comes in
late antiquity
judaism kind of paves the way
and then we get thoroughly within the
medieval period how do these medievals
think of themselves i love these these
medieval shows where they actually talk
about themselves as being medieval or as
being in the dark ages because
the dark ages yes people did actually
think of that not as the dark ages but
it's something tantamount to you know
the end of the world and the scourge of
god coming upon them because
civilization was crumbling because of
these barbarians but if you actually
look at medieval history
and you approach it with fresh eyes and
you look at medieval texts what do you
find
you find a constant
ferment of intellectual
and physical and organizational work you
find progress taking place
all over the place every monastery that
went off to the wilderness
not only to to you know
be alone so they could say
they could think about god did not just
you know
replicate old texts they added to things
they founded schools they cultivated the
earth towns formed around them because
they were
instruments of progress
and
if you actually look and you actually
read medieval thinkers you will find out
that those dark ages
quite often were not as dark as
the later ages made them out to be nor
do the medievals necessarily think of
themselves as heading towards something
or being in between something
they did look to the past because they
thought that the people in the past were
not a bunch of dummies and still had
something to offer them and yes there
was at times you might say a slavish
devotion to the past but was that often
the case
read some medieval texts and find out
read thomas aquinas read augustine read
ansel
and see
just how slavish followers they are of
aristotle or augustine or you know plato
or pick whoever you want you won't find
that to be the case at all
as a matter of fact here's one thing
that i actually use in some of my
classes you may see this is a little bit
like digression
um
saint anselm i asked my classes in the
middle ages was that people think the
world was flat or wrong oh they all
thought it was flat
really then why does saint anselm say
well you know the world is this globe as
we all know
in the sense that hey we all know this
i'm going to begin from some starting
point because it'll make sense to you
and then it's called really that's
that's the case where did they get this
weird notion that that the medievals
were all these sort of united people of
faith who put their trust in blind dogma
and
you know didn't think about things
they got it from later on didn't they
some interesting things do take place
you know the renaissance the reformation
contributions to the world of ideas
but you know those who are continuing on
with this may continue
throughout the
age
to rethink things you can find thomas
philosophers today who are taking up all
the great thoughts
of these figures and trying to
assimilate them aleister mcintyre is a
great example
norris clark another great example
now from the perspective
of the reformation of the renaissance
they were both trying to imagine a kind
of
antiquity of moments you know what was
the reformation about let's get away
from this church
let's get away from these accretions we
need to get back to original
christianity what was the renaissance
about we need to get back to the
original insights and the texts and the
beautiful ideas and the ways of life
that the the greeks and the romans had
yeah you know
there's something to that
what goes on in modernity modernity
and especially the enlightenment
understands itself
as
one of two is
either
counterposed all of this
which was bad
or as you know beginning with the seat
of this which goes back to this and all
of this in between here the medieval
fusion
this was all bad this was dark ages this
is foolishness this was
priest craft this was you know
superstition we could go on and on and
on
what's interesting about modernity is
that modernity unleashes forces that
cannot actually be controlled
within the
what we you know one philosopher called
the dialectic of enlightenment and
eventually it leads to all sorts of
crises all sorts of collapses all sorts
of
people who just don't believe in
the modern promise the way that some of
the early moderns
represented and the way that
some of their contemporaries were you
know going on in a very dogmatic fashion
about that
and some terrible catastrophes took
place economic political
military um you know
to do that and now we find ourselves in
a time that some people want to call
postmodernity and i call it late madeira
they follow it following jameson because
i don't see it as fundamentally detached
from
the modern thing and i see much of
postmodern stuff as just cycling around
within the modern
or at best replicating some of the
insights that the medieval has actually
expressed and expressed much more
systematically and with more insight
so
if we want to ask ourselves
fundamentalists
let's say we're talking about
fundamentalists in the strict sense
are they medievalists
no because they're not returning to
anything remotely medieval
nothing like the synthesis of faith and
reason and the sort of discourse and
debate that went on first in the
monasteries and in scholastic
sorry in monastic theology and
philosophy and then even more in the
schools in scholastic philosophy and
theology before it became worldwide
contemporary fundamentals they're not
doing anything remotely like that as a
matter of fact
where do you locate them
thoroughly within modernity
now here's where i actually have a
suggestion an idea
and i get this from
fascist studies
there have been a lot of different
theories about what constitutes fascism
there's no absolutely general agreement
within the field
there have been a lot of you might say
half baked or cockamania theories you
know the marxist one that the fascists
are just agents of the bourgeoisie uh
clearly not you know an inaccurate
conception of fascism uh some people saw
it as sort of a return to
um you know prim it more primitive
or you know pre-modern ways of being
invited
i think that the better theories out
there are that fascism
is not just anti-modern not just archaic
national socialism too and integral
nationalism that's what happens with
abbreviations
i buy the idea that they have different
vision of modernity so what goes on when
fascism comes on the scene is very
similar to what's going on
when marxism and communism comes on the
scene
we are being presented with a
fundamentally different
version of what modernity should look
like and should be doing
from within modernity itself it may take
some pre-modern elements to it but
everything has some pre-modern elements
actually if you look at it carefully
i think that this also
here's where you know i
have some suggestions that i think
people
could could reject
or might say yes that makes some sense
i think that fundamentalists in the
strength sense where we're talking about
this i think that they fit that same
dynamic
they are you might say a kind of
anti-modernism
only by virtue of being modern
being so thoroughly modern that they can
reject it from the inside out and they
can reject what they see is as you know
detritus as non-essential to it the uh
liberal or the you know in our political
spectrum conservative
way of having what we call liberal
democracy
which is not in fact you know the
form of political life that makes people
the most enthusiastic
i think that you can say the same thing
about totalitarian islam
and i want to be very careful to stress
here
i do not think
that
all muslims are totalitarian in their
conception of things i do think that
some of what we call islamic
fundamentalists
or radical islams are better described
as totalitarian
islam not you know islamofascism or
anything like that i think that it's a
different type of totalitarianism
in some ways
more difficult and to deal with and with
greater standing power and of course its
own history going back
all the way to
an intellectual crisis after
the monuments came in and smashed some
of the muslim
powers
i think it has a much greater
ideological base than fascism
or any contemporary christian on the
mount which is fairly non-political
action
um but i think that all three of these
and
these two things
christian fundamentalism fundamentalism
the strict sense
totalitarian islam are both things that
get called by the term fascists or not
fashion
fundamentalism actually some people do
call it just fascism too
so
i think
that
perhaps
what we should understand all of this is
is something going on here
something going on purely here
and
haven't lost any sort of real contact
with the medieval
views on things i'm less convinced about
about islam when it comes to that
i do think that a lot of the muslim
conceptions of muslim
middle ages are rather
hazy and ideological
um
you know a lot of the things that that
went on are things that that islamic
totalitarian muslims do in fact reject
but that's that's still something that's
a different thing so
are fundamentalism medieval or
anti-modern i think the answer is
clearly that they are anti-modern